nous sommes le vendredi 17 février
attention journée internationale de la
gentillesse spontanée
[Musique]
ça fonctionne bon bonjour
la fin des débats sur la réforme des
retraites a été à l'image de ces 10
derniers jours chaotique à minuit pile
les débats sont clos sont que l'article
7 sur l'âge de départ à la retraite
n'était abordée les députés de la France
insoumises quitte alors l'hémicycle en
chantant
le con de la majorité Anthony la
Marseillaise
un son de soutien qui n'est pas la
colère du ministre du Travail
vous m'avez insulté 15 jours vous sortez
mais vous m'avez insulté personne n'a
craqué personne n'a craqué et nous
sommes là devant vous pour la réforme on
s'y exprime librement
tu es prêt
[Musique]
tribune la tribune attention compète de
cela entre Stéphane et Antoine regardez
hop là c'est bon Stéphane
mesdames messieurs bienvenue chez les
fous kourtney Kardashian qui a lancé il
y a quelques jours un produit pour
préparer au mieux la Saint-Valentin
[Musique]
moi j'ai toujours aimé raconter une
histoire drôle c'est mon plaisir c'est
une de mes inspirations grâce à une des
amis de ma mère qui était une grande
conteuse ça peut être tata Ginette je
l'adore cette femme elle est partie à 98
ans c'est ce qu'elle a dit elle a dit
j'arrête de fumer et ça et sa petite
fille elle lui a dit pourquoi elle fait
parce que je viens d'apprendre que ça
rend stérile
alors présenter comme ça ça paraît
presque pas mal mais quand on voit
qu'elle promet que ça améliore la
fraîcheur l'odeur et le goût du vagin en
un petit doute
[Musique]
six lettres du côté de d'Aymeric ça
semblait pas se passer comme ça
un verbe
je suis enceinte depuis six mois et je
me pose énormément de questions mon bébé
peut-elle tomber enceinte par exemple si
je fais l'amour pendant ma grossesse le
sperme peut-il aller dans mon bébé et la
mettre enceinte j'ai posé la question à
mon docteur il m'a certifié que non mais
je ne le crois pas à 100 % voilà vous
voyez l'ignorance et le pire pour les
hypocondriaque avec les web ce sont les
fake news santé qui sont la réponse
comme disait le docteur
j'ai une vie très occupée comme beaucoup
de gens je trouve que la mienne elle est
elle est vraiment elle est vraiment très
très remplie avec cette matinale et puis
après avec la radio et puis avec un
enfant un mari quelques copains quand
même et les gens me demandent toujours
comment tu fais pour en fait faire tout
rentrer comme ça et c'est vrai que
ah voilà on y arrive voilà
les chercheurs se sont rendus compte que
la taille moyenne des érections à
systématiquement augmenté depuis 1942
elle a même augmenté de 24%. des 30
dernières années
alors le plus cool le plus cool le plus
cool
si ça tombe sur moi ça va mal se mettre
moi ça m'est arrivé d'avoir des
situations de malaise extrême parce que
j'entendais ça m'est arrivé de coucher
avec une fille et que la fille me dit ça
fait en plein milieu de l'acte elle
s'arrête elle dit attends mais quand je
vais raconter à mes potes
que je suis en train de coucher avec toi
mais c'est dingue et moi c'est fini
après à partir du moment là à partir de
ce moment-là j'étais c'était impossible
de durcir j'étais en Christophe
Dechavanne
on est passé donc de
12,27cm à 15,23 cm c'est extrêmement
précis attention alors est-ce qu'on en
déduire
à tout de suite après une toute petite
pause le temps de de tailler votre
crayon par exemple
mieux que des fleurs ou du chocolat pour
la Saint-Valentin une oeuvre d'art un
cadeau signé Banksy le célèbre street
artiste britannique on y voit une femme
visage tuméfié et souris et bréché
poussé dans un congélateur un homme dont
seul les jambes dépassent il y a des il
y a des Sports vous faisiez au lycée à
d'autres le foot d'accord
pour enchaîner les pompes et surtout
pour que cet été j'arrive avec un corps
d'apôtres les babab
41% des jeunes utilisent Tik Tok comme
moteur de recherche et estime qu'un
influenceur suivi peut être une source
fiable d'informations
parler de la planète de surconsommation
de la crise économique c'est bien pour
la jeunesse sur ces images je tournais
en Chine on voit des dizaines de
streamers sous un pont en train de faire
des live en leurs abonnés l'endroit n'a
pas été choisi au hasard il s'agit d'un
quartier aisé de la ville grâce à la
géolocalisation tous espèrent retrouver
par de riches internautes et obtenir
ainsi des dons plus généreux l'astuce
semble fonctionner vu la concentration
impressionnante de vidéastes chinois
dans certains lieux
les projecteurs
l'espèce est rare la photo est encore
plus cette américaine a remporté le
titre de photos graves sous-marine de
l'année pour ce cliché d'un dauphin rose
d'Amazonie pris au coucher du soleil
parmi les 6000 photos en compétition le
jury a également distingué cette baleine
dont la nageoire est coincée par une
corde de même que le repas d'un requin
baleine ou la trompe immergée d'un
éléphant la vie minuscule célébrée aussi
à travers cette photo d'un bande embryon
de poisson